ba-leep grande now weep ninny bong yeah
that's a real line said multiple times
in this movie oh boy so time for a
patreon sponsored review and this one I
am I gave fair warning when when I was
asked to do this one and I'll give you
folks fair warning as well because I'm
about to talk about the Transformers the
movie the animated one from the 80s and
I'm gonna be approaching this as almost
a total outsider I know what the
Transformers are I'm aware I grew up in
the ATO it was hard not to know but
transformers and GI Joe are semi blind
spots for me because like I know of them
and I knew their basic deal and some of
the big-name characters but I never
watched either show I never had the toys
for the one outlet I was
he-man Real Ghostbusters and Thundercats
that that was my poison back in the 80s
so the only piece of transformers media
I've ever actually taken in is the first
live-action film I have not seen any of
the other live-action films because when
they started coming out and everyone
said wow man the first ones the best my
thought was I didn't even really like
the first one that much and if thats as
good as it gets
yeah I'll just check out now I'm well
aware that that live-action is not
considered by most fans to be
representative of the property so like
I'm not gonna hold any of that against
it but just realize that I'm coming in
with basically a little bit of osmosis
knowledge I couldn't name most of the
characters in this law definitely
couldn't name most of them before that I
watched the thing now having finished it
I probably still still couldn't name
most characters in it so you know this
is not this is not a fan perspective
this is not this is somebody with no
nostalgia for this property so if you
have nostalgia for it if you grew up on
this the way I grew up on something like
the rankin/bass Hobbit and you have an
absolute love for it terrific hahaha I'm
not coming at it from that perspective
so realize that before I get started I'm
not gonna be as cool as you might think
I would be based off that intro though
because there's actually a lot of fairly
impressive stuff going on here
so especially in terms of the design
work unicron especially like the the
front end and like the inner workings of
Unicron when it devours that that planet
it's actually surprisingly elaborate and
kind of horrifying and well speaking of
horrifying the body count on this thing
like I I knew that Optimus Prime died
and I knew that like a decent number of
other characters were killed off because
the film's kind of notorious for that if
for some reason you don't know and I'm
gonna be talking to plot pretty much the
whole way through so not really a review
to watch if you don't want spoilers if
for some reason reason haven't seen it
yet but like going in the the mandate
for the filmmakers was to kill off a
huge chunk of the cast so that they
could push the new characters ie the new
toys coming out so there's a
surprisingly high body count on this and
the thing was like detailed like not
leaving a lot of room so like the first
few Autobots start start getting hit
start getting dropped and I'm like oh
okay and then like the like the third
one he gets shot like it's specifically
zooms into his face you see the light go
out of his eyes and smoke come out of
his mouth oh my oh wow okay and a little
bit later like an insecticon gets its
head crushed under a wheel and um later
on there's some transformers getting
melted and acid
ha and the thing wasn't I couldn't tell
you the names of and of most of these
characters that died but I know that
they had them
I know these were named characters in
the TV show up to that point so the way
that I can think about it is it's like
if the very first Star Wars movie and
that fight in the hallway when the
stormtroopers come through and they're
gunning down the rebels you know before
Darth Vader gets his first big entrance
in in a new hope
imagine if Pryor's the release of Star
Wars there had been a TV show that had
been running for about a year where
those characters those dude that just
get gunned down into the hallway had
names and back stories and histories
that people have been following them and
loved them and they just yes I mean it's
it's ballsy I'll give it that the
animation actually looks pretty good too
for I mean yes I kind of judge on a
sliding scale for anything that isn't
Disney or Don Bluth when you're talking
80's animation but it's it's pretty good
again the design work does a lot of the
legwork the annamund the actual movement
not the smoothest stuff in the world but
they get away with it pretty well
largely for the inventiveness of of
what's going on and what's being shown
and the the plot as it moves alike I was
I was surprisingly engaged certainly
through the first act as it moves along
it started to lose me because it's one
of those situations where after the
first act everybody's goal becomes clear
and then it just becomes a matter of
stalling everybody so mega Megatron
effectively is critically wounded in his
fight with Optimus Prime a fight that
Optimus Prime ends up dying from
Megatron that ends up hooking up with
Unicron who reforms him into Galvatron
which is a little bit of a shame because
they have
leonard nimoy come in to do the voice
and you know the voice work from the
regular cast some of the voices are
annoying which is par for the course
with 80s cartoons but you know they know
what they're doing and they know how to
deal with this dialogue and you can kind
of tell Leonard Nimoy's there to pick up
a paycheck
like even more so than Orson Welles as
Unicron so like that's a shame
considering how kind of you know
invested at the the Megatron performance
was but anyway so like Galvatron has a
mission to destroy the matrix of
leadership and he keeps thinking he's
done that and then going back to you
know granny's I know you didn't then he
gets sent back out again and you know
the hero characters they have this place
that they plan to go and they just they
get broke it off and splintered off and
well now they have to deal with this
they have to deal with this their goal
never changes they just get they just
get delayed on the way there so it it
and in in ways that aren't like
particularly organic although in not in
uninteresting ways because we get
divergences like the junk planet and the
really weird sort of Court thing that
some of them get stuck in some of the
other weirdness though the song use I
mean first of all the songs on this they
are super 80s holy cow and one of the
weird things about the song use is they
they almost always use nearly an entire
song every time they use one which
doesn't sound weird but really stop at
thinking about it when you are used to
hearing a song get played in a movie
it's like maybe a verse in the course
like usually that like even in the 80s
where they were belting these the themes
are written especially for the movies
thing you still usually only get a
little bit of the thing at a given time
whereas here they just let it keep
playing even as the mood of the scene
shifts and that can result in some
totally odd stuff where you know okay so
it's fine that Optimus Prime shows up
and
you know in his triumphant leap into
battle with that hole you got the touch
and you know all that but the fact that
it keeps playing that song while he's in
his battle to the death and taking what
will ultimately prove to be mortal
damage from Megatron yeah so that's a
little odd but they keep playing if the
songs not done yet that's really weird
when they use Weird Al's dare to be
stupid which I have to wonder if like
somebody in the directing or editing or
some part of this like just had a head
like a staring at themselves in the
mirror moment and ended up using that
song because the point at which at the
very end where it just kind of repeats
to be stupid it's after I think like the
third recurrence of the the universal
greeting that thing that I said at the
opening and right after it you have
weird outgoing do to be stupid I'm like
the movie did movie just dared to be
very stupid it's it's so weird
I mean this movie's really bizarre at
points yet it is engaging it's not dull
it's not dull it's not boring and I'm
not even sure I could call it bad it is
just weird there are some annoying
characters I think Daniel the kid is
completely unnecessary and also
irritating because he almost never held
he helps like once towards the very end
and in a way that was not a with that
you know any other character could have
also helped him so it didn't have to be
him and then in addition to that you
know you've got I mean well
you've got hot rod who's kind of
irritating not a big fan of him either
but you know you've just got a couple of
irritating characters like that I mean
the big thing with Daniel for me is like
we're in the middle of climax any trips
and falls I'm like you gotta be kidding
me leave the kid behind so
then but there isn't too much of that I
I find the Dinobots a little bit
annoying with the whole sort of Cookie
Monster speak that they've got going on
I'm not not a huge fan of that but I do
why I like I said I like a lot of the
design work and I like a lot of the
environments there's a lot of creativity
going on in this I do have a couple of
general questions though I'm not like
actually kind of I'm not I'm not trying
to like highlight these as plot holes
but these were thoughts that actually
occurred to me as I was watching it so
the first is like we go to several
different planets and we're always
encountering transformers of some kind
his earth a fluke is all the other
sentient life in the universe
machine-based is only earth organic life
because you'd think if the Transformers
like only came from Cybertron that when
they go to other planets they'd be
running into aliens but they know they
only ever run into transformers if
they're anywhere other than Earth a
travels transform is that prolifically
spread out or is robotic life the
standard I was just sort of a that that
one that didn't bug me too much the one
that did actually kind of bug me a
little bit what's the line where
transformer can't be repaired anymore
because there's a couple of character
because Optimus Prime
dies at about a third of the way in to
this movie at the climax of Act one
Optimus Prime
the most popular character the leader of
the good guys he dies and later on you
have what appeared to be much more
damaged characters like the character of
cup and then especially Ultra Magnus who
literally gets blown to pieces and that
gets put back together later I'm like
that look if Optimus
I couldn't bounce back from his injuries
but you got literally blown into
multiple pieces and you got to be
reassembled how does that work so that
that that did actually kind of take me
out a little bit when they reassembled
Ultra Magnus cuz I'm going wait a minute
wait a minute you know given all the
ones that all the characters who did die
who look like they suffered much more
repairable damage than what he did I
don't think I have too much more to add
like I I was kind of I was kind of
afraid of this I was kind of afraid that
watching this was gonna be like oh god
is this just gonna be a painful slog
through other people's nostalgia no like
while it by no means was this ever gonna
connect with me the way it would have
with anyone who watched it when they
were young or anyone you know who grew
up on the Transformers as a property but
I can look at this and go I see why
people would be into this I could see
how if I had been introduced to this at
the right age I could have been into
this like I get it I get the appeal of
this and I think that says a lot right
there because you know oftentimes with
these things you'd look back on them if
you were if you were never there in the
moment you're going how was that a thing
I can watch this and go no I get it I do
I get the appeal of this I get why this
was the thing it's still a little bit
too too weird and and haphazard for my
taste
but I have a glad that I saw it so
thanks for patreon the the patreon
sponsor who who kicked this my way so
yeah that'll wrap up for this particular
one the transformer is all blurry have
you seen it what do you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about a whole bunch of things you
can do there's buttons and there's links
image so the patreon already I won't
mention it again there's other links as
well don't want to check any of it out
don't worry about it because at the end
of the day folks
you are the council I just run the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]